hello my name is Andrew Jones from  artistic brit on youtube today's one  minute monday is born of a lifetime of  creating inventing and having  entrepreneurial dreams bigger than life  itself dream bigger i made a discovery  years ago i was dreaming way too small  for my abilities instead of entering  that contest why not hold your own event  instead of having a booth at that show  why not hold your own exhibition for  some dreaming bigger will simply be to  spell out thinking yourself and just go  for it get going and get it done it's  incredible when you simply continue to  put one foot in front of the other and  do not doubt that the answers will come  there you will and finally of course as  always believe South improvement books  are like fitness books they never work  on their own what you need is a trainer  that's Evan get the newsletter  you